ではよろしくお願いします
69番からお願いします
ネバダンマパダの69番
マドゥワマンニャティ バアロ ヤーヴァ パアパン ナ パッチャティ
ヤダーチャ パッチャティ パアパン アタ バアロ ドゥッカム ニガッチャティ
ということで マドゥワっていうのは蜜の如く
いわゆるハチミツですね
甘いもの 蜜の如くマンニャティ感じる思う
バアロ 無知な人が ヤーヴァ パアパン ナ パッチャティ
パアパン 悪がナ パッチャティっていうのは熟しない
ヤーヴァっていうのは限り
熟しないまでというかね
悪が実るまでは 悪が果報を出すまでは
愚か者は蜜の如く感じているんだと
悪行為を感じているんだっていう意味なんですね
ヤダーチャ パッチャティ パアパン
ヤダーっていうのはその時ですね
どんな時かというと パッチャティ パアパン
悪が熟することになっちゃうんで
いわゆる結果を出すことになるんですね
その時 アタ その時 バアロ ドゥッカム ニガッチャティ
その愚か者は本当に不幸に
苦しみに陥ってしまいますよと
それほど難しい言葉ではございません
悪いことをする時はね
ものすごく蜜の如く美味しく感じるんです
楽しいんです しかし 結果出る時はとてつもない苦しみに陥るんです
だから世の中ではね いくらあれこれと言っても悪が消えませんね
世の中で悪いことはなかなか消えません
良いことは簡単に消えてしまいますね
ある一時期で良いこと
良い社会があっても すぐそれ崩れちゃって
悪い社会に 悪社会になってしまうんです
一旦悪い社会になってしまったら
なかなかそこからは抜けられないんですね
で それはどういうことかというと
悪いことをする時 あのほんのわずかな時間なんですけど
その時はすごい幸福じゃなくて刺激を感じるんです
だから心っていうのはこの悪感情でできていて
感情がどんどん溜まっていくと
ものすごくイライラして
ストレスになっちゃって
何かしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから欲 無知 怒りがもう溜まっちゃうと
そこは発散するために何かするんですね
それが悪行為なんですよ
怒ったら怒鳴るとかね
怒ったところで もうなかなかいてもたってもいられなくなります
そこで そこを発散するために思い存分怒鳴ったり
いろんな悪いことをしたりする
物を壊したり 人を殴ったり
人を殺したりする 殺しなどはほとんど殺しやら暴力は怒りで現れるんですよ
欲でもいろんなたくさん悪が世の中で起きるんです
だいたい世界はもう派手に怒りのことは気になったりはするんですけど
欲でやっている罪の方が結構多いんです
あまり気にしないだけで
欲はいいと思っていて
怒りは良くないと思っていて
だから怒りを正当化する人々の数が少ないんですけど
欲を正当化する人々の数っていうのはものすごい圧倒的に多いんです
そういうわけで 我々は気づくこともなく
正しいと楽しいと楽しいんじゃないかと
気持ちいいんじゃないかということで
いっぱい欲で罪を犯しているんです
悪をしているんです 全然気づかないんです
数少ないんだけど 怒りでも同じことを悪いことはやってはいます
暴力を振るったり 人を脅したり
そういうことを人を殺したり
釣りをやったり 魚釣りっていうのは
あれはホビーというか趣味ではありません
あれはもう怒りなんですよ
平和で 水の中で 自分の世界で
誰にも迷惑をかけないで生きている生命を片っ端から釣ってやって
また自慢までする これぐらい大きいものを釣ったとかね
だからその場合は怒りはどこにあるかなんか分からないでしょ
でも欲と怒り すごいごちゃ混ぜごちゃ混ぜ
もう回転しながら回転しながら回転しながら
で まず魚釣りをやって楽しみたいというの場合
欲なんですけどね しかし
魚釣る場合は怒りなんです
逃げようとするともう殴ったりいろんなことをしますからね
糸が切れそうになっちゃうと
何か棒を持って魚でむちゃくちゃ殴ったりしてて
とにかく取ったりはする
取って殺してからまた自慢気にどうだい私の腕というふうに
またそこで欲なんですね
で そういうふうに我々は何の嫌悪感もなく
何の注意することもなく
何の危険を感じることもなく
すっごく簡単にスラスラスラスラと日常生活の中で悪いことをやっているんです
だから心の本来の姿っていうのは
ものすごく暗くて すごい危ない
すごい臭いんです 美しくはないんです
心が貪瞋痴で無明と渇愛っていうのは基本感情なんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
まあ無明っていうのは
心は本来正しく認識しない
そんな認識 正しく認識しようというつもりもない
だから勝手に物事を認識したりする
そこは無明であって そこからはもう刺激欲しいというね
心を回転させるために刺激欲しいということで
渇愛が生まれてくるんですね
だから死にたくない 生き続けたいとか
そういうあらゆる感情っていうのは
その渇愛の結果なんです
二つの煩悩といえば もう無明と渇愛
別なカテゴリーに分けてみると
また別なたくさん出てきますけど
煩悩は二つにまとめたければ
無明と渇愛という単語二つになります
渇愛っていうのは まあ生きる
生きたいというね 欲であって
無明だから生きるとは何なのかとわかってないにも関わらず生きてがありますからね
それはまあ無明というんですね
なんでそんなに生きたいのかと聞いたら
誰も答えを持ってないんです
そんなにもなんで生き続けたくなるのかと
答えを持ってない 毎日の生き方はどういうものかとね
まあ今日一日はどんなものかと
そうやってもう一応記録でもしてみると
毎日の生き方ってのは碌なものじゃないんですね
もうあっという間に時間過ぎ去ってしまっただけで
やりたいことがあっても全部できなかったし
あるいはやりたいことをいっぱいやって
もうもう半分しかできなかったとかね
それで悔しい思いでなっちゃうし
まあいろいろなことはありますからね
今日楽しみたいなと思っても
いろんな仕事があって
もうそれもできなくなっちゃうし
だから結果的にはもう素晴らしい一日でしたということはなかなか言いにくいんですよ
それで毎日そうやって記録してみれば
本当に記録してみれば
今日もつまらなかったということでほとんど終わっちゃいますね
月に一回か 三ヶ月とか一回ぐらい
今日楽しかったという風にね
言えるかもしれませんだけど
今日もつまらなかった
今日もすごく疲れましたとかね
今日も失敗しましたとかね
そういう日に記録してみると
そういうことになりますよ
今日ももうなんとなく一日終わりまして
虚しかったとかね だから人間自意識的じゃないんだから
そういう風に記録してみようともしないんですね
偉そうにあれは書いてますね
なんとかっていうやつはね
毎日あれ何て言いますか
日記 で 毎日日記書いてるんだったら
今日一日の評価も書いてみたらどうですかね
正直に だからそれも満足度にした方がいいんですね
今日の満足度 五つ星になるのかと
まああの そういう風に客観的には人はやろうとはしないし
それはダメやと言うんですね
まさ逆に そんなことするなよと
今日はすごく良かった
楽しかったとかね 明るく見なさいよとという風に
ものすごい無知の方向へ持っていくんですよ
だから明るく見なさいよとかね
人生楽しいと思いなさいよとかね
生きていればいっぱい楽しいことあるんだよと
はっきり言いなさいよと言ったら当たり前分かりませんしね
生きていれば楽しいこといっぱいあるんだよって言うでしょうね
でははっきり言いなさい
何が楽しいことあるものかと
ただ何一つないんです
なのに生きていきたがるんです
そこを無明というんですね
無明からこの渇愛も出てきて
渇愛っていうのは分けてみればたくさん煩悩になります
それで渇愛 欲と一緒に怒りがいつでもワンセットになるんですね
欲っていうのは 自分の心が希望するプログラムで生きることは欲であって
でもそれは成り立たないんですね
自分が思う通りに生きるということは
世の中では成り立たないんです
別に自分で自分の意思で生きているっていうことでもないんで
ただ生きているだけ 因果法則によって
だからもう希望通りに行くんじゃなくて
物事は因果法則によって動いているんです
法則ですからね 自分がいないんです
法則で生きているんです
法則の勝手に だから人間一人一人
何の立場もないんですよ
何の権力も 何も立場も
何の力もない ただ法則の中で
まあもう回転しているだけ
なのに 一人一人の生命には自分勝手に考えたプログラムがあるんです
このように生きていたいと
その我々勝手に作るプログラムは決してその通りに行くということはないんです
勝手にプログラム作っても
因果法則の中で生きていなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 自分のプログラムと因果関係がマッチしたらうまくいった気分になるんです
希望通りにいきましたと
それ楽しいと でもなかなかそのマッチするのはなかなか難しいんですね
まあ例えば まあ自分がみんなに愛されてほしいとプログラム作る
しかし その人のことを愛するか憎むかということは
周りの人々の勝手自由だからね
それから相手の態度っていうのは自分の行為によって成り立つんだから
相手もわざわざ人を憎みたいと思ってはいないし
もうもう愛してほしい
愛してあげたいとね 大事にしたいとは思ってないんです
だから相手の人々はこの人々の対応に
態度に対する適切な反応するだけ
そちらにしても だからみんなに愛されてほしいと思っても
結果どうなることかとわかったものじゃないんです
だから社会は自分が決めるようには動くわけではありません
社会だけじゃなくて自然もそうでしょうね
自然は我々言う通りに動くものじゃないんです
そちらにそちらの法則があるんです
だから法則によって動くだけ
そういうことだから もう心の中で自分のプログラムあるということで
必ずプログラム通りにいかないという
たまたま因果法則がそうなってプログラムとマッチする場合はあります
それは期待通りに行ったと言うんです
本当は期待が叶ったんじゃなくて
期待もありましたけど
因果法則がそれなりに揃ってしまったんですね
揃って出した結果と期待と比較すると似ている
だから期待通りになったということになるだけで
期待通りにはいかないんです
期待通りにしたい人が仏教を学ばなくちゃいけないんです
物のことは期待通りにやりたければ
なぜかというと もう期待があったら
期待は主観であって勝手なものだと仏教の人は知っています
これは叶うはずもないと知っています
その人はさらに知っています
結果っていうのはどのようにあり得るのか
それは因果関係であると知っています
だから 自分が期待してした結果出すために
どのように因果関係が揃っちゃえばいいかと
そこを調べて因果関係を揃えるんです
因果関係が揃ったら 確かにその当たり前の結果が出る
その結果が自分が計画立てた期待する結果と似ている
それで期待通りに行ったとなります
なぜならば その人は努力したんだからね
期待を叶うために で その努力もなしに
ただ願っただけでは期待通りには物事は行かないんです
それで因果法則が語っているのは仏教だけですからね
科学世界でも物質の因果関係はまあ発見はしていますけど
それほどそれでも完全に発見し尽くしているということじゃないんです
なかなかはっきり発見できない状態に入ってしまったんですね
科学は いつでも物事は 1 たす 1 は 2 であるという法則でいかないんですね
物質も どうしてもどこかで不確定ということが出てくるんです
だから最終的にはこの量子力学やらいろいろのものが出てきて
科学的な理論がね やっぱりこのプロバビリティーというね
確実でないって 何て言いますか
確率がすごく少ないというかね
だから本当の姿は何なのかとわからないんだと
例えばこのものを観察すると
観察しようとした時点でそのものが変わっているんです
そこで観察する間はそれなりに
その観察する対象が変化するんですね
それで観察者が変化をチェックして科学論理作るんです
観察をやめたら その対象がまた別な態度をとるんですね
だから実際は何なのかとわからないんです
だから 目に見えないものは X線で見ようとする
ある物体に X線当たっちゃうと
その物体が変化するんです
変化した結果はフィルムに収めるんです
それで X線当たることをやめちゃうと
また別な変化するんですね
観察されてないんだから
自分の法則でその物体が動いているんです
そこでこんなものがあるんだと科学者が発見しましたと
あのレントゲン写真見てみんな驚きますけど
実際はそうでしょうかと
だから科学研究の場合でも
やっぱり 研究できるようにデータが取れるようにと
あらゆる工夫して調べるんです
だから最終的には ものの存在って何やとわからなくなってるんです
だから一般的にこの まあプロバビリティー理論とかね
まあ不確定の論理とかね
なんたらかんたら まあ私は科学は分かりませんだからね
明確には理解することはできませんだけど
まあやってみると 物質と心っていうのは
もうこれ一体で機能するんだよっていう話にするしかないんです
物質があるっていうことは
知ってるのは心だから
心なしに物質があるっていうことは言えないんです
だから心がなければこちらにマイクロフォンがあるっていうことは言えません
マイクロフォンっていうのは本当の姿じゃないんですよ
人間の認識で考えた物体であって
だから人間でなくなったらマイクロフォンの存在はないんです
決してマイクロフォンはマイクロフォンらしくは働きませんよ
人間がいないと 我々で推測しちゃうと
ただの物体として 錆びてもカビも生えたりして
いろいろなことを起こるでしょうね
マイクロフォンとしては機能しません
だからそちらの人間の心はどうしても必要なんです
だから私たちは物質があると思ってますけど
それは私たちの心を無視して言えるものじゃないんです
ではね 心がなかったなら物質あるかないかと
それは言うことはできません
だからナーンとルーパっていうのは切り離して語ってはならんというのは仏教の立場なんです
ナーンは心 ルーパは物質
だから人間がもう一応推測で推測で
宇宙のこともね ものすごい推測ばっかりなんですけど
もうあらゆる推測して宇宙の存在は知ってますけど
全部心と関係あるんです
心関係ないものっていうのは
存在するっていうことはわからないんです
だからお釈迦様のでなくて
まあたまたま一つのエピソードありますけど
このただ考えるだけ で
かなりのものはわかるんだったよね
で 妄想するだけ妄想することじゃないんです
ちゃんと考えるというね
まあ実験何もなくても
考えるだけでも わかってしまうというね
一応一つエピソードがありますけどね
ある人が何かどこかでインドでね
お釈迦様時代 池のところで座っていて
宇宙のことを考えてやろうではないかと
生命の起源とか何だらかんだら考えてやろうではないかと
それでずっと考え始めたんですね
だから妄想する人には何も言られません
だけど 考える人はそれなりに客観的にこうですから
こうなったり そうなるためにはこうならなくちゃいけないし
そうなるためにはこうならなくちゃいけないしとかね
そういう風にずっと考え方にふけっていたんですね
それで その人の目の前にすごい現象が現れちゃったんです
全く常識では信じられない現象なんですね
ものすごい軍隊が現れてきて
ものすごい大量で 自分を見ているこの池だから
そちらハスの花とかいっぱいあってね
全部軍隊があの 1本のハスの花の中に入ってズルズルズルズルと下へ行くんですね
ある一箇所から この人驚いちゃったんですね
こんなものすごい大軍がどうやってこの1本の花からね
決まってる ある場所 穴から場所からずっと下へ下へ下へ潜り込んでいく
ああ やられたと自分が
これはありえないことが私には見えているんだと
だから私は完全狂っているんだと
本人は決めたんです で
これは昨日のちょこっとそういう話ありましたけど
あの日本の皆様とは違いますね
なんか変な音を聞こえたり
変なものが頭に浮かんだり
見えたりすると これこそ事実だと言って偉そうなこと言いますけど
あのインド人は逆でしたけどね
この変なもの見えちゃったんだから
これはありえないんだから
私は病気だと それとはっきり決めたんだ
だから立派な哲学者なんですよ
どう考えたってハスの花の中から軍隊はいるわけじゃないから
それでさっさともう世間のことを考えることをやめて
親戚を呼んで皆様気をつけてくださいと
私はもう頭はイカれているんだと
なぜかでこういうことを見てしまったと
ですから 私は自分の生き方にはもう自信がないんだと
だから皆様方はすごく気をつけてくださいと
立派な人なんですよ そこでその人はね
ある日 今お釈迦様にも会うことがあって
お釈迦様にも会って お釈迦様にも先にこれ言っていくんです
気をつけてください 私は本当はものすごくイカれていますけどと
だからもし何か変なこと言ったら
お釈迦様は気をつけなくちゃいけないだけのことと
で なんであんたはそう言いますか？と言ったら
実はこういう出来事が見えたんだから
それから本人は自分の思考は信頼しないんです
と言ったら お釈迦様は何言ったかというと
あのね あんたイカれてないんだよと
あなた見た出来事はかつて起きたことだと
その空間で 実際に あなたは過去で
かつて実際に起きたことをあなたに見えたと
ではあんたそれで興奮して大変なことになって心配までして
今自分で自分が頭イカれてるんだという宣言までして
だからあの人が私の頭おかしいと宣言するとおかしくはないんですよ
頭おかしい人は確実にあなた方より私は真面目だと言うんだからね
だからあなたはいともたっても入れられない状態になったんだと
だから余計なことを考えるなよと
お釈迦様はこのいろんな次元を超えて知識を得るのは科学的なアプローチでちゃんと方法があって
それは身についているんだから
驚いたり感動したり興奮したり
頭イカれたりはしません
あるプロセスで淡々と淡々といて
それで結果は出てくることだけだからね
で その人にはこの世の中のことは考えてはいけませんとね
これではもうもうどうにもならなくなっちゃいますよということで説明したんですけど
だから考えただけでも物事を知られるということはね
あり得るということに
私はそのエピソードを使ったんですよ
そこでどういうことかというと
ものの存在っていうのは心を抜きにして成り立たないんです
私たちのこの普通の思考では
それはちょっと把握できないだけ
この素粒子の研究やらね
そういうものをやっていると
もうなんかいきなり今までの物理学全部崩れ崩れてしまったという話もあるでしょうね
だって物があるといえば
一箇所にある時間で一箇所にしかいないでしょうに
でも素粒子は今同じ時間で箇所にも現れてますから
現れますからね 本当は個の素粒子なんです
なんで個の素粒子が同じ時間で箇所に現れるのかと
あれでまた一つになるんです
素粒子だから これはもう切ることも切って 2つにすることもできない
だからこれどう見る考えるべきかというふうになって
このものとして見るか
波動として見るか どちらかというのはなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそちらにもあるのもこの観察者の心なんですね
だから論理的にはこの一番小さな単位
これはもう割れない素粒子だから
単位をそれ流してみて
じゃあ邪魔しておくんですね
邪魔しちゃうと これ 1個割れないものだから
このバリケードから左か右に
寄ってそれから進まなくちゃいけないでしょうに
これがそうしませんね
バリケードは無視して両側から出て行って
また 1個になってしまうんです
という何とか実験みたいですけどね
あと実験と言ったってものすごい推測でやってますけど
やっぱりそちらにも観察者の心が入っているんだということになっているんですね
まああの まあ余計な話になりましたけど
まあ心と物事っていうのは
やっぱり 抜けて考えることはできない
物があると言ったっても
結局は心があるという話になります
それで科学世界では物にかかっているんですけど
物があるということは心があるっていうことですから
心は何なのかと心に関わらなくちゃいけないのに
心次第で物はどうにもなりますから
物を研究したって意味がないんです
我々 科学者ではなくて
普通にわかるでしょうに
例えばキャベツがあったら
我々の心次第で食べ物にもなるし
我々の心次第でそれはゴミにもなるし
あるいは毒にもなるし
ではキャベツは本来キャベツは何を失ったものじゃないんです
すごい腕のいい料理屋さんにがキャベツを取ったら別なものになっちゃうんですね
その人はそのキャベツを見て認識するのは別物で
料理作ったことは何もない
子供がキャベツ取ったら別なキャベツなんですよ
子供に認識する 子供が認識するキャベツは
もう怒りでものすごく怒りで憎しみで人がそのキャベツを取ると
また別なキャベツになっちゃうんですね
だからごく世俗世間の中でも
この真理はじりじりとあるんです
だから このものすごい深いところまで行く必要はないと
お釈迦様の説法だからシンプルなんですよ
同じ法則だとすべて だからもう毎日日常生活の中で見てみると
全部宇宙の真理も心の真理も全部見えてくるはずなんです
だから包丁っていうのは何者でしょうかね
知らないんです その人の心次第なんです
だからすっごい怒り 憎しみの人が包丁を取ったら
それは凶器になるでしょうに
料理人がそれ取ったらそれは料理の道具になるでしょうに
それで今日は朝 部屋に怖い男の子が泊まっていたんだから
あの子にも紅茶飲みますか？とか言ったら飲みますよって言ったんだから
家と言えば私は楽なのに
で 紅茶入れて まあ私はそのまま飲みますけど
まあじゃあ黒砂糖でもあげようかねって言ったら
もうここに黒砂糖あって
これが柔らかいというと
もう石10倍にしたぐらいもう硬くて硬くて
これ小さく切ろう 全く
もうもう切れるところのダイヤのカッターあったら切れると思いますけど
で 私は包丁で切ったんです
なんのことなく包丁はハンマー代わりに使ったんです
これはハンマーで叩き潰さなきゃもう割れませんだからね
包丁の切れない背中の方で
それでむちゃくちゃ叩いちゃうと一応割れたんです
だからその私の心次第でしょ
その瞬間で それはただのハンマー代わりになった代わりになっただけで
切るものではなくて割るものになった
ものを割る道具で だからあれは包丁かハンマーかもう凶器かってわかったものじゃないんです
ですから 物質にはそんなに独立した特色はあるのかと
物質の働きっていうのは
結局は観察する人の勝手にあります
だからものは心次第でどうにもなりますということになるんです
だったら研究するべきのはもののことじゃないんです
もののこと研究したっても切りがないんです
心次第でものが変わるんだから
そういうわけでブッダはいきなり心の研究にして
心次第でものが変わるんだよということを証明してみせたんです
だからものはそんなにどうってことはないんだと
それでこの人間の心が汚れているというよね
だから何やってもうまくいかないという世界でしょう
そこで今日もあのこと一緒にこのメールを出したら
いて百五十ぐらいメールがあって
で 必要というか メールとしてあったのはたった一枚だけで
他全部スパムメールで
これぐらい大量のデータをね
もうプロバイダーで保管しなくちゃいけないし
それで私はダウンロードしなくちゃいけないし
それですごく時間かかるし
ダウンロードしないでいるわけにもいきませんし
自分に送ったメール何なのかって見なくちゃあかんから
全部ざーっと並んでくるし
そこで世の中にあるとあらゆる悪い商売
汚い醜い商売の宣言ばっかしで来るわ来るわ来るわ
それで電子メールシステムというのは今ものすごく便利で
仕事をする場合はものすごい便利でしょうし
経済的でしょうし 早いでしょうし
普通のメール メールで普通のメールで手紙を送るよりは
瞬時にやりとりできるし
領収書を出すにしよう
何か見積もりする送るにしよう
もう何でもできるでしょうに
だからすごい便利な道具なんですけど
今各コンピューターを壊している代物になっているんです
だからビジネスというのは全部メールとしてくるんだから
それで誰か誰か計算もしていたんですね
どれほど商売時間をロスするのかと
このスパムメールのせいで
仕事をする時間なくなっちゃうんです
で 外で瞑想会なんとかに行ったら
帰ってきたらメールボックスを綺麗にしなくちゃいけないで
それで大体ものすごく時間かかるんですよ
一回でできない あまりにも大量だからコンピューター引っかかっちゃうんです
それでメールプログラムまでフリーズするんです
そうすると私はまたコンピューターのシステムに入って
そこはまた解除して 一旦再起動までして
また立ち上がって また次の大体三回
四回ぐらいになるんです
それで七千ぐらいメールが来て
それ全部まとめて削除しなくちゃいけないんです
それで今日もう一人人がいたんだから
この連中どうやって住所知ってアドレス知ってるのかと色々にところチェックしたら
時々結構アドレスは正しくある場合もいい加減な自分のアドレスいい加減なのに
自分のアドレスでもないのに来ているというね
それで何言いたいかというと
メールプログラムは代物になるか
えらい迷惑なものになるか
犯罪を起こすことになるか
子供はもう不良に走らせるものになるかっていうことは
結局メール次第じゃないでしょ
インターネット次第じゃないんです
人の心次第ですよ だからものはこういうものであると決めてはいけません
決められません いいものか悪いものか
どちらかも 無には特色
いいと悪いというのは人間の勝手ですからね
それでもなく これは何なのかということは言えません
言うことも不可能なんです
それは認識する人の人次第なんです
だから 汚い思考を持っている連中が
メールプログラムをそのように認識する
あ これだったらこんなことできるんだぞとか
これだったらこういう風に人を騙せるぞとかね
というわけで 世の中いろんなものは作って現れますけど
こんなこれでいいのか悪いのかわからないでしょう
どんなものでもそうなってますよ
例えば東京という街がね
とんでもないビルいっぱいできちゃって
もう世界でも大都会というか一つでしょうね
これってすごいことですか？とんでもないことですか？どうやって言いますかね
やっぱりその人の心次第です
どんなものでも認識する人の心次第で
この例で覚えてるキャベツは毒になる可能性もあるし
ごちそうになる可能性もあるし
ただの生ゴミになる可能性もあるし
とにかくどうなるかわからないんですね
それは認識する人の心次第ですから
面白いことは キャベツはしっかりとそれに対応するでしょ
認識する人の心に合わせて自分が性格変えるんです
キャベツさんが それってものと心の関係でブッダはそこから語られているんだから
科学者がぶつかっている問題は仏教にはないんです
素粒子の研究は仏教でやってもないんです
宇宙望遠鏡の開発はしてないんです
何もないんです しかし
あれほど金かかって科学者が達する論理は
より先に真理を語っているのです
はい そういうことで それで心の本性って何やというと
これ暗いんですね もう暗いというんじゃなくて
この暗黒なんですね あの宇宙のものを探っている科学者が
このダークマターという概念があるんですよ
ダークマターっていうのは
この宇宙の大きさやら重さやらね
いろいろ計算してみたところで
何か計算合わないんですよ
観察する物質の重さと重力
あれこれ計算すると 宇宙はこうなるはずがないんです
重力足らないんです 5
分の4ぐらいから5分の3ぐらい
今は何か固まって スパイラル状態で宇宙が回転しているでしょう
そういう風に固まってもらって
あらゆる星々がそういう風にスパイラル状態でぐるぐるぐるぐる回転させるためには
ものすごい引力が必要なの
それはもう質量でしょう
全部計算してみても質量が足らないんですよ
3 分の 1 ぐらいかな もうちょっと忘れちゃったんで調べたんですけどね
どうしようかと それで彼らが考え出したのは
観察に入らない質量があるんだと
それにはダークマターというんですね
黒い物質 だから観察に入りません
しかし 残念なことに この黒い物質の量がすごく多いんですね
だからそちらに適切な質量があるんだから
宇宙はこんな状態で固まって回転しているということになるんです
それで問題はダークマターあるかないかということよりも
やっぱり心でしょう 心になって心が納得いきたいんですよ
心が納得いきたいんだから
ダークマターの概念を作る
そこで最近読んだ記事で
なんとかの方法でダークマターの存在は成立できそうだと言っているんだからね
そこであるということになるんです
そこで人間には確かにあることになるんです
実際あるかないかではなくて
認識世界ではそれが作るんです
これは否定それから否定できないんです
結局は認識が物事を作るということになっちゃうんです
だからアヴィッジャパッチャサンカーラになっているんです
最初からアヴィッジャっていうのは心なんで
無明がある心で この無明という原因でサンカーラというのはもうあらゆる現象がもうというかこのポテンシャルが生まれてくるんだと
そこからナームローパだよと
そこから心の存在と物質の存在が成り立つんです
そんなつまらないものを言ってもね
まあなんかもうあまり脱線しすぎだから元に戻ります
で 心の本来の状態は黒くて臭くて汚れているんです
その心が物事を認識しようとするんです
だから我々知っている世界は一切で不完全で汚くて不公平で理不尽で苦しみで悪循環になっています
で 心次第で 物はあるかないかわからないはずなんです
物は独立してどんな状態かとわからないんです
科学者さえも 我々あると思っているものは全部心があるんだからあるんであって
ないとは言えません だからないんじゃないのかと
いいえ そうじゃないんです
あると言っても心次第であるんです
まあシンプルな例で分かりますよ
例えば暗い部屋で あの
何か花があるとしましょう
それであの花何色と知りたくなる
光当ててみるでしょうに
あ これはピンク色の花です
あの部屋がある 本当？あれ
光当てたんだからピンク
ピンクの顔を見せただけであって
それから何やってるかわからないんですよ
暗い部屋の中であの花が
だからどんな人を言ってみても
ライトを当ててやっぱりピンク色
過ぎないと やっぱりピンク色である
その都度その都度 形変えるんです
それで識別能力のない人が見たらピンクじゃないでしょうに
それで識別能力はちょっと問題ある人に
とか灰色に見えるかもしれません
その人は灰色の花として対応するんです
その人には灰色の花と花として花も反応してくれるんです
ピンク色やと思った人にはピンク色の花としてその花さんが対応してくれるんです
そういうこと それでその本来心っていうのは悪で汚れていて
煩悩で無知であるんだから
その心やることというのは一つの善行にはならないんです
感情で 本能でやるものは一つも善行にならないんです
で だからみんな喜んでやるものはもう不善行為なんです
だからそんな難しくない
我々悪いことをするとすごく気分がいいんです
そこでお釈迦様はこの科学より別なものを発見しているんです
この因果法則っていうものは観察次第じゃないんです
因果法則の本当に難しさはそちらにあるんです
だから これも人間にはわからないんだと
因果法則は 人間にはものは心次第であるものだっていうことをわかりにくいでしょう
変に感じるでしょう 因果法則っていうのは
観察者抜きに物事のありさまなんです
それは観察者に関わるところだけお釈迦様が教えたんですけど
そこで業論が出ているんです
業は自分の認識と関係ないんです
業っていうのは因果法則なんです
我々私たちは欲しかろうか
嫌かろうが関係なく業は出なさるんです
で 花はピンクか白いか灰色かっていうことは我々の観察次第ですけど
業は観察次第じゃないんです
受け取り方で変えることは相当難しい
かなりできますけど それでも
一旦業が機能すると物質と心が機能しますから
物質と心はこちら認識するんだからね
それでこちら認識次第で変えますから
そのセクションだけは変えられますけど
私は手術すっごく痛かったんですけど
もう我慢できない もう人間に感じられないほどのものすごい強烈な痛み
私はこれって面白いなとか色々この痛み
色々観察しているんですね
観察してみたら そんなことくだらんこと感じたって痛いでしょうと自分に言うんです
それで看護師さんが「どう？痛いんだったら言ってください」って言うと 「
うるさい」と 「言えるところじゃないでしょ」と 「
言いたいんだけど 言えるところじゃないんだ」と 「
そんな力もない」と というくだらんことを考えながら
逆にじゃあ観察次第で確実に私にとってすっごい面白い経験になりましたし
もう初めての手術ですよ
生まれてから これ結局それで冗談じゃあやっぱり業から逃げようと思ったところでまんまとハメられたと
業からは逃げられないんだと
普通に日常生活に微妙に不便があっただけのことで
これを手術すれば治りますから
それから楽々にいるそうと思ったところで大間違い
もう六年分ぐらいは苦しんじゃったんですね
それで六年は生きていられませんだから赤字なんですね
だから業が勝ってしまったと
だからそこは観察者から離れているものなんですよ
しかし 私はあの時間で別に何の苦しみもなく
ものすごく面白くて いろんなくだらんことを考えたり
いろんな冗談やら漫才考えたり
したんですけど 楽しかったと
本当は痛かった だからそこで自分
観察者として自分のアプローチによってそうなったんですけど
客観的な事実としてはもう強烈に痛かったという
忍耐制限そろそろ超えるというところまで痛かったんです
しかし それに泣いたり
拒めたり あれこれ言ったり
もう狂信になったりとか
そういうのは全くないんです
その時でも返事しなくちゃいけないとか
何かちょこっと冗談で何か言ったりとか
[笑い]だからまあ だからそれは自分で管理できるセクションで
しかし痛みは痛みでなくなるっていうことは管理できないんですね
それはやっぱりここで観察さと関係なく起こる
起きていくんです 仏教ってなんかややこしいですね
南無妙法蓮華経とればこりゃけるんでそれだけでいい
簡単ですけど それで因果法則っていうのは観察さと関係なく
物事と心のありさまなんです
因果法則は 物事は心が認識するもので
それでこの心が認識する物事と心のありさまが因果法則なんです
だからその発見というのは
発見して教えてくれたら楽に我々は理解するかもしれませんだけど
楽々はないんだけど いくらか何となくでも理解するかもしれません
発見したっていうことは
もう相当なものです だから生命
一切生命の中でブッダほど知恵の人はいません
それで何のためにそれを言ったかと
この単純シンプルな芸なんですけど
悪をするときは楽しくてたまらないんだから
みんな悪しか知らない
やらないってことになってますけど
一旦行為してしまったら
それは因果法則の管轄になっちゃうんです
それから自分の責任から離れているんです
自分にはどうすることもできないんです
それで行為にふさわしい結果が出てくるんです
出てくる時は否応なしにくったくたその人は不幸に陥れるんです
いくらこれはおかしいんだ
これは理不尽ではないかとかね
いくら言ってやっても意味がないんです
誰にも悪口を言ったことはない
誰ともニコニコと笑う人がいてね
誰見たってもこんにちは
親御さんもちゃんと挨拶したりする人がいたっても
どこ行ったら誰かに殺される可能性あります
誰かに誘拐されちゃって
くったくたいじめられて
拷問までされて もう食べ物も何もあげないで
それから殺されたというようなことはいくらでもあります
こんなのは理不尽だ 残酷だと今更言っても
これは誰にもどうすることもできません
これは因果法則の管轄
認識は超えています 頭で理解しようとしたら無理です
なんでそんな人はそうなったのかと
そこで単純な時間で計算すると
人を殺すのはちょっと十分で終わります
それから受け入れなくちゃいけない苦しみは十分で終わりますかね
それにはどれぐらい長いかというとね
この人を十分以内で人を殺してしまったから十分でしょ
だから私を苦しめるならば
ちょうど十分にしてくださいと
はないんです それから無制限
無制限ではないんですけど
かなり無量の時間苦しまなくちゃいけないんです
なのにそんなことをやるということを無知という風にしか言いようもないんです
人のものをパクッと盗むのは簡単
二 三分なんで 例えば万引きするともうあっという間に万引きできますよ
どれぐらい時間かかりますか？万引きするために
それは知らない やってみてください
で それってあっという間にできますよ
しかし 万引きがバレたところの苦しみは
このこのこの人生だけに計算してみたっても
あっという間ですかね
だからそのところは宇宙法則にも関係ない
心の法則にも関係なく
因果法則で起こるんです
関係なくではなくて関係ありますけど
何と言いますか 独立して機能するんです
業っていうのはそういうものだから
業は人間に理解できないと
だから業のことを考えるなよと
考えて理解できるのは物質のことなんです
だから観察者抜きに起こる法則っていうのはもう考えられ考えきれないんですね
人間の考え 能力 範囲を超えています
ですから 心のことと業のこと
宇宙のことと まあそんなですね
それからブッダは何者かということも同じで
だから一切全てのことを知っている人の知識はこんな程度やと我々に言う
測る 測ることできないでしょうに
そういう項目はやっぱり考えないで置いておいてくださいと
説かれてはいるんです
それで 我々は気をつけておく必要があるところは
この悪いことっていうのはやりやすい
ハチミツの味  3つの味
悪いことは そういうところで気をつければ
だから当然良いことをすると何かやりたくないという気分が入ってきます
本来の心が悪だからね
良いことはやりたがらないんです
しかし 同じ法則で良いことをしたっても
これはあっという間にできるし
しかし 結果もまた無料の時間で良い結果になります
この偈を語ったのは このものすごい美しい女性がインドにいたんです
ものすごいもう美人で
ウッパラワンナという名前なんですけど
ウッパラっていうのはこのある一つのスイレンというんですかね
このハスのではなくて
もう一つ水の中で咲く花があります
微妙に青いんですけど
すごく美しいんです で
その花の名前を入れてるんですよ
で名前を入れたのは そのように美しいんだと
この方は あまりにも美しいんだから
もう大変困ったことで
いろんなところからもう
お嫁にもらいたくなるんです
そこで父親が大変なことになったんです
いろんな国 何か国の王様たちが自分に出してくださいとかね
地方のすごい大金持ちあれこれとかね
うちのくださいとかね
どうすればいいんだ父親は
大変なことになっちゃったんです
すごい美しい性格のいい娘が生まれて楽しかったんだけど
原子爆弾持ってきたような感じで
それで父親が考えたのは
これではもう家族みんなむちゃくちゃになる
国と国の戦争になる可能性もあります
もし自分が住んでいる国の王様の方にも欲しがっていて
まあでもあの人は年上だから
隣の国の王が若いしね
あの人にあげると言ったところ
大変なことになるでしょうね
その父親が考えたのは
この娘さんにね 君 どうですかね
この再婚やめちゃってね
出家したら 言った途端
彼女はもうあれほど美しく生まれたっていうことは
すごい徳があることでしょうね
いきなりものすごく喜んで
まあそれだそれだと 私ももう父親が何か言うんだから言えなくなって黙っていたんですけど
ものすごくもう私も出家したかったんだと
ったところで 父親やら親戚は自分の命を守るためでもあって
もう娘を尼寺に連れて行ったんです
で 出家したんです 彼女はもう身で
身をもって知ってますから
この欲の世界っていうのはいかに怖くて恐ろしいものかと
だからもう欲にはこりごりということで
一生懸命修行して まあ大阿羅漢になります
仏教の世界ではもうお釈迦様のサーリプッタ
モクレン尊者でしょう
あの弟子たちが 尼さんの場合はケーマーという尼さんとウッバラワッナーって尼さんなんです
だから一番トップなんです
どうかおかしい このケーマーさんもすっごい美人で
ウッバラワッナーさんももう桁違い美人なんです
二人とも で 彼女が悟ってからはね
まあ森の中で まあちょっとしたちょこっと屋根を葉っぱで作って
なんかまあ洞窟みたいなところで
まあ一人で生活しているんです
しかし 彼女の生まれたあの辺で
小さい時からも彼女のことを知っている男の子がいたんです
幼なじみの 一緒に遊んだりとかいろいろやっていたんだからね
ちっちゃな時からもう
この男の子はもう小さい時からもうこの女の子のこと好きで
好きで どうしようもないんですね
まあ好きだけでね もう一緒に結婚しましょうとか
そういうところまではいけないしね
彼女はカノジョの立場の人でしょうし
そこで出家したところで
もうこの若者にはどうしてもこのウッバラワッナーのことを忘れられないんですね
だから彼女が托鉢に出た時に見張って
部屋に入って 寝るところの下で隠れていたんですね
隠れていて ウッバラワッナーさんがね
もう托鉢終わって部屋に何のことなく戻って
部屋に入ったところで
この人がもうこの尼さんを捕まえたんです
そしたらこの彼女はもう体触るなよと
とんでもない厄になりますよと
目覚めなさいよと あんた何をやろうとしているの？いくら言っても体力で抑えて暴行死だったんですね
犯しちゃったんです これ大阿羅漢でしょうし
これは極限な罪なんです
普通の尼さんで犯したらもうものすごい極悪になりますよ
阿羅漢になったらもうものすごい
それより苦しみの方がものすごく長いんです
この迷惑さえ起こしたら
この地球の時間でこの太陽系が壊れると地獄も壊れてしまいますからね
それで罪の刑期が終わるんです
それと関係ない地獄もいろいろあります
時間制限がリミット成り立たない
で これこの人はそれやって外に出ただけで
そのまま地獄に落ちちゃったんです
そのエピソードについてお釈迦様に語られたという偈なんです
それからはママさんたちには一人生活することは禁止したんです
いつでも尼さんたちが自分たちのグループを作って
で 森の中生活も禁止で
まあそれなりの人々がいるところで住むようにということで
で まあ楽しみはつかの間だよと
悪いことする時は でもその悪業が出てくるともう無量だよと
愚か者はそれを思わないんだと
それでこのそのまま地獄に落ちたという人が何人ですね
デーヴァダッタさんと次
この人なんですね もう一人はいたみたいですけどね
この出来事について このなんかみんなもうギャーギャーギャーギャーと大騒ぎになりますけどね
みんなまた疑問を持ったんですね
いくら阿羅漢と言ったっても肉体の体でしょうと
で 男に触ったりすると
いくらなんでも感覚が生まれるんじゃないかなと
だからそれってどういうことでしょうかとか
みんな余計なことをガチャガチャガチャガチャもう
考え出しちゃったんですね
阿羅漢は欲を冒さない
悪いことしないのは当たり前
分かりますけど 抑えつけて暴行したらしちゃうと
体あちこち触ると その時でも
もしかするといい感覚が生まれたんじゃないんでしょうかねとかね
言うと これにお釈迦様がかなり怒鳴ったんですね
阿羅漢になった人にはそれは全くもありえないんだと
で 初霜の葉っぱの上に水一滴落としても
葉っぱには全く触れることはないんだよと
水は落ちるかもしれませんだけど
葉っぱはもう毛がいっぱいありますから
微妙に触れることなく弾くんですね
あるいはこの針の 針っていうのは刺繍の針の
あの あの棘のところの上にマスタードの種を乗せますかと
乗せられません 落ちます
そういう感じで この観測に対しては
阿羅漢の心は完全無欠で
もうそれはないんだよと
まあ心はそれぐらい観測に対して
情報に対して触れないようになったところは阿羅漢であると
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌心が初霜の葉っぱに水が落ちるような感じになったならば
もう阿羅漢であるということなんです
初霜の葉っぱに水が一滴落ちちゃっても
すぐ落ちるんです 止めてやったっても
もう濡れてないんです
だから阿羅漢になった人には目にものが見えるは耳に音は入るは舌に味は入るは
しかし 受け取り方はあのような受け取り方
中には入れませんよと
だから  それは一つの認識の仕方でもあります
だからものは何やということは認識者の勝手でしょ
だから阿羅漢になった人には
ものは因果法則で無常でしか見えません
ものとしては取れないんです
ものというのはあるっていうことだからね
マイクロフォンだよと言ったら
マイクロフォンはある
存在するっていうことになるんですね
ある 存在するっていう言葉が変わらないって意味なんです
しかし 認識者次第で変わってますけど
これは みるみる人の心によって変わっています
変わった反応するんです
そういうことで この阿羅漢になるっていうことは
この観察仕方変わって
因果法則という真理 無常という真理というところで
だから無常と言えば形がないんですよ
無常というのは変わるっていうことだから
一つの形描いたっても意味がないんで
これ変わりますから すぐ
変わることっていうのは何にストップで変わるんだからね
1時間ごとに変わるならば
形がありますよ  1時間ごとに変わるんじゃなくて
絶えず変わるんだからね
形で色では取れる まあよりは完全な心で物事を見る人には別な物事は見えるんです
うん  そんなところです
またこの四百一偈でまたウッバラワンナ長老の大阿羅漢の話が出てきます
その時は阿羅漢の心は綺麗ということの説明だけなんです
その出来事からは比丘尼たちはね
尼さんたちは町に住むべきやっていうことになったんです
比丘たちだけ森で お墓でいろんなところでいてもいいんです
じゃあ話はそういうところで終了いたします
[終始背景音楽]